well and tell us the other day Democrats
appeared to be divided on the question
of impeaching the president this week
they appear to be nearly unanimous but a
few holdouts are warning that an
impeachment push is a mistake bad for
the country and possibly kind of
productive politically one of them is
congressman Jeff Andrew represents New
Jersey he's one of those holdouts he
joins us tonight congressman thanks so
much for coming on it's my pleasure
we'll be with you
you're an ear a Democrat a guy will say
a conservative Democrat but but you're a
Democrat and the easy thing would be to
go along with your party's leadership on
this question but you're not why I've
never been good at that to begin with
you know just you know very briefly
people will say you know your job is to
be a good Democrat or a good Republican
and I keep emphasizing your
responsibility and job is to be a good
American so I go what I believe in my
heart is right and in my brain and it
seems to me at this point in time we
really do want to accomplish some goals
infrastructure needs to be dealt with
healthcare needs to be dealt with
prescription drugs need to be dealt with
you know election you know elections
need to be dealt with as far as making
sure that they're secure I can give you
a whole long list Tucker the point is I
really believe the more that we delve
into this the more time we spend on it
especially at a macro level the more
we're not going to be able to spend time
on these other issues that are important
and it's not because we can't walk and
chew gum at the same time because
somebody brought that up we can walk and
chew gum at the same time the problem is
when we're this divided when we're this
split there's two political parties and
this is all going on people aren't going
to work together so the president's not
going to be signing bills the Senate
bills aren't going to be going through
the house the house bills aren't going
to be going through the Senate and at
the end of the day I'm afraid that all
we're gonna have is a failed impeachment
because folks need to understand I mean
maybe there are those that want to
punish the president or make a point and
I understand that but the bottom line is
he's still going to be the President of
the United States right and the bottom
line is he is still going to be the
candidate for the Republican Party so
why don't we let the people do the
impeachment by voting in the electoral
process the way that we usually do
oh you mean democracy okay yeah
absolutely I love not a popular concept
it wasn't it so but I mean I guess the
political question of course I agree
with everything that you said and I
commend you for caring about those
issues because I think they are
bipartisan fundamentally but everything
you said is pretty obvious I mean no
offense died or one of us but it you
know anyone can figure it out
including the smart people who run your
party so they know they're not going to
get a conviction this isn't going to
work there's no chance of it working so
why are they doing it I'm not sure I can
answer that I think part of it is they
believe that the president should be
held accountable for some things that
he's done and you know by all accounts
nobody ever pretended that he's perfect
or there aren't some issues but you know
I always used the example even during
the Clinton administration and when that
impeachment by the way I was also not
for that and we saw that it didn't
really bear any fruit wasted a lot of
time and money but he had some serious
issues there and he even lost his
ability to practice law he was disbarred
but with all that happening it still
wasn't nearly enough for impeachment to
go through here's what folks have to
understand impeachment is a very very
serious serious move to take by any
political party or political entity you
know we have to realize that when you
impeach somebody it has to be for really
strong reasons because you are also you
know removing the power of the people
your disenfranchising their vote whether
we like it or not whether we like who
wants not your disenfranchising their
vote and it has to be serious to do that
so my my worries are getting stuffed on
I really want to do good things and I
want to do it in a bipartisan way I
really want to see the country move
forward I really know that you know this
and abroad I think that people could
look at this and think that our country
is disorganized and turmoil that were
split apart and I think it'll split
people in society apart I think folks in
the in literally in the United States of
America are even going to get angrier at
each other I don't believe it's going to
bring people together and that's what we
need to do and then we have the election
and the other issue by the way is these
are the midterm
elections are going to be going on now
and then we're rolling right into the
full elections for President and
Congress cetera and I don't know that we
need to have all this going on at the
same time I agree with that
and again as you just pointed out voters
get to render a judgment a little over a
year
you know we sure do there sure does Ben
thanks so much for joining us today I
really appreciate it it was great to be
here thank you